a las vegas man could be next to
blastoff into space he's a finalist
for a mission to bring eight artists to
the moon it's called project dear moon
eight
victoria saha tells us how this man's
passion for astronomy landed him in the
top 20
from all around the world john
carmichael has always looked at the
world with a different lens
the 35 year old self-made
astrophotographer's passion for space is
evident through his work
he is most famously known for his
capture of the solar eclipse in 2017.
i can't believe i had a visual of this
all my life basically
and it came together and and i
looked at all the flights around the
country and compared them to the moon's
shadow path
carmichael's love for astronomy started
at a very young age but he didn't pick
up a camera
until he was 20 years old it started out
as
using my camera as a tool to be able to
see the things i wanted to see
carmichael chased our solar system with
this camera across the globe
which has now helped him land as one of
the 20 finalists out of a million
applicants that could go on the first
civilian mission to space
and the moon the day that they announced
it i
i just got brought to tears yusaku
maseiwa is a japanese billionaire he
bought eight seats of the rocket made by
elon musk's space
x now he gets to choose who gets to join
him the space enthusiast watched the
launch of the blue origin and hopes to
be next
this is what i used to dream about as a
kid to
one day space would be accessible to
everyone
and that's what's happening we're living
this is the future now carmichael is
openly gay he says his number one goal
is to share this experience with people
from different backgrounds
and capture the moments with them on
board and share it back here on earth
victoria saha 8 news now carmichael will
be notified
any day now of selected to go on the
week-long journey to the moon and will
have to spend a year and a half getting
trained to be an astronaut
the mission set to take off in 2023
denise any day now he's going to be
notified can you imagine
how he's feeling like every time the
phone rings is this the call
so excited he's even answering spam just
in case
my feed the one he's waiting for